Sammy Wilson the UPnP for East Antrim is
with us now hello to Mr Wilson thanks
for joining us
um this morning
um after the prime minister's visit to
Northern Ireland the dup leader your
boss Jeffrey Donaldson saying
um that we should see that faced I'm
quoting a big moment to agree the right
deal for Northern Ireland what is the
right deal for Northern Ireland
great deal for Northern Ireland is first
of all to ensure that Northern Ireland
is treated in this exact same way as the
rest of the United Kingdom in other
words that the laws which apply in
Northern Ireland under UK laws not EU
laws we've now left the EU that the
people in Northern Ireland have got the
ability where the issues are devolved to
decide what laws that we have applied
here not Brussels and as a result of
that then all of the other issues about
barriers to trade and checks on Goods
would no longer be necessary
um and that really is the the objective
that the Prime Minister has to achieve
when he uh negotiates with the EU so far
what we've had is some tinkering with
the protocol but the fundamental issue
of the protocol is that Northern Ireland
is now separated from the rest of the
United Kingdom that's impacted on the
Union in fact the active Union has had
to be changed as a result of that and we
are we find ourselves economically
disadvantaged because Goods can't be
brought in from GB without going through
a border checkpoint and being checked or
else there's huge bureaucratic barriers
put in the way of GB firms trading in
Northern Ireland those are the issues
that need to be addressed
um I think most people would agree that
that oven ready deal was probably Half
Baked and something does have to be done
but what do dup do if um the UK and the
EU reach an agreement without your
involvement
well we will then continue to refuse to
implement it and that means that we
cannot participate in the Storm at
assembly because essentially if a deal
is agreed which still keeps us within
the EU single Market
as ministers in the Northern Ireland
assembly we would be required by law to
implement that deal and we're not going
to do that because we believe that such
an arrangement is designed to take us
out of the United Kingdom and they would
take us out of the United Kingdom
because increasingly we would have to
agree EU laws which diverge from UK laws
and in doing so would separate our own
country from the rest United Kingdom
We're British
and we expect to be governed by British
law not Brussels law and we've certainly
not collaborate in administering
Brussels law in our part of the United
Kingdom
you say you'll be obliged by law to
carry out the agreement but you would
refuse to do that so in other words you
would break the law
no we wouldn't we would simply refuse to
participate in the assembly and of
course under the Good Friday agreement
because we are we do live in a divided
Society the assembly can only operate if
there is a consent of both unions and
nationalists to a top relation and to
what goes on now and if our consent is
to be
not given to the uh the laws which were
required to administer then the assembly
can't operate that's as simple as that
and you know I think Ian Duncan Smith
yesterday made a very very good point
the government has a choice either it
can protect the Good Friday agreement or
dispense with it in order to comply with
the demands of of Brussels and the EU I
think that the UK government has
streamed it to first of all protect
peace in Northern Ireland protect the
union not the European Union the union
of the United Kingdom and that's what
the outcome of these negotiations must
be otherwise you know that's
unreasonable to ask your nurse to
participate in an arrangement which is
designed for the breakup of the Union
and that's what's at stake here and
that's why this is a historic moment for
the Prime Minister he's going to choose
is he the prime minister of the whole of
the United Kingdom or is he the prime
minister of part of the United Kingdom
who's prepared to abandon another part
to the demands of the Europe the
European Union
uh would he make her suggestions over
the weekend that the Prime Minister
before last Boris Johnson has been
tinkering around
well first of all
um what he Boris Johnson has said is
that it makes sense in negotiations to
have as much leverage as you have as you
can and one of the ways of achieving
that is for the government to see the
Northern Ireland protocol bill which
would in effect give the government uh
in in Westminster the the right to act
unilaterally if they can't reach
agreement with the European Union his
argument has been that you've got far
more leverage if you've got an
alternative to uh the outcome of the
negotiations that's something actually
we have been arguing for since the
protocol bill was introduced and if the
former prime minister is now saying that
he believes that's a good tactic as well
then we welcome that and I hope that the
government does listen to that because
our fear is that they've gone into these
negotiations with an attitude of defeat
almost they have not seen the protocol
Bill through the House of Lords they
have already taken uh pars from the
storment government to uh Implement uh
border control potion build border
control posts of three ports in Northern
Ireland again to try and please EU and
they've aggravated the Handover
commercial and trading data to the EU
something which EU had been demanding
all ahead of reaching any agreement and
you know it does cause you to wonder
sometimes about your negotiating tactics
why do you give the other side all of
the things they wanted for before they
give you anything in negotiations
just before I let you go Mr Wilson I'm
not sure if you are a betting man or not
maybe
um on the Gold Cup I'm not sure but if
you if you were a betting man um do you
think there'll be a deal over the line
this week
no I don't and I think that the Prime
Minister probably has done big things at
the weekend as well because he realizes
there there are barriers and Hills to
climb and um he knows the kind of issues
that have to be dealt with I hope that
he does go into negotiations with a full
understanding of what is required we
have got seven tests but don't forget
our seven tests are no different than
what the Prime Minister has promised he
wants to seek as well because in the
protocol Bill and in the command paper
which the government published last
bottom uh to deal with the protocol they
were asking for exactly the same things
as I've been talking about here this
morning so
um he knows the Gap that exists at
present
and I hope that he intends to keep on
group negotiations until that Gap was
closed
good to talk to you thanks for taking
the time much appreciated thank you